la universidad de santiago entrega
gratuitamente 400 ejemplares de la nueva
propuesta de constitución la campaña por
el plebiscito en chile se ha centrado en
que se conozca y se debata el texto
constitucional para que todos los
chilenos voten teniendo conocimiento del
documento
jordania agradece hacerse con una copia
oficialmente
una manera informal me parece muy
importante informarnos para votar
informado y tomar una muy buena decisión
con respecto a lo que al futuro del país
algunos chilenos desestiman
constituciones falsas que se han
distribuido durante la campaña y luchan
contra la desinformación bueno por red
social igual se divulga mucha
información está decir cierta o falsa
pero aquí mismo tenemos un agobio
original entonces para informarnos por
nuestro propio medio la mayoría de las
encuestas dan como favorito al rechazo
desde hace meses los partidarios de esta
tendencia reunidos aquí al caer la tarde
apuestan por que no se apruebe el texto
constitucional por calificarlo como
divisorio
divide el país dificultad
el manejo del país
[Música]
en estos días es habitual encontrar en
chile- en lugares donde se lee la
constitución los partidarios de la
prueba creen que el texto habla por sí
solo parte de la familia de nancy de 72
años fue ejecutada en dictadura ahora
espera que esta nueva constitución que
contiene artículos explícitos sobre la
prohibición de desapariciones forzosas y
respeto a los derechos humanos cambie
esta situación para siempre en el país
bien por lo suyo
es muy
muy justo este gris o algo que quede
absolutamente explícito a los derechos
de los disidentes
e ideológico en la carrera del
plebiscito el rechazo parte como
favorito pero las encuestas se han
equivocado antes en chile y la gran
incertidumbre es cuántas personas
participarán en la primera elección con
voto obligatorio desde 2012 y hacia
dónde se inclinará su voto